well first of all thanks for giving me
the opportunity to speak and took care
of me for organizing this is jeremy said
I spend a lot of time working on the
palm oil issue I used to manage a palm
oil plantation for about 10 years down
in Costa Rica so know the business quite
well and the process quite well and when
i joined WWF you know I was not really
expecting to spend so much time on Palm
thought it would be spending some but
then I got out to Indonesia and got to
see the magnitude of the damage that's
going on and what's really happening on
the ground out there and for someone who
has been in industrial AG production
agriculture for all of my professional
life really came away just incredibly
shocked at what was happening because I
had never seen such kind of horrific and
just wholesale slaughter of just
everything in sight and so really wanted
to dig into that and started to dig in
see how do i click this thing really
trying to figure out how can the
industry out there in Indonesia and
Southeast Asia be transformed into the
development of much more sustainable
fashion and it's a really complicated
question just because there are so many
different facets to the palm oil issue
that not there is no one single solution
to this problem in terms of how do we
move this sector it's interrelated with
global trade increased income zits
alleviating poverty a whole slew of
multiple issues and land use policies
that are all colliding because of this
it's kind of a forward I do want to say
you know we aren't against Palmer palm
oil was not the problem the problem is
about how palm oil is being developed
it can be a great crop for development
it's a simple production technology it's
the z's and pest tolerant it produces 12
months out of the year so it provides a
steady cash flow especially for small
holders which is important very few
inputs from a chemical side essentially
just fertilizer and a little bit of
herbicide grows in variable soil types
and variable climates highly profitable
and when done right can actually enhance
biodiversity and be carbon positive when
done in certain landscapes in a certain
regions so palm oil could be a good
thing but the problem is is just how the
sector has chosen to to expand it just
as a little backdrop kind of what's
happened most of you probably never
heard of palm oil until you probably
came here to really understand kind of
what's happening but you've seen a real
transformation in the edible oils market
or the vegetable oils market in the last
20 years or so and palm oil way back in
nineteen eighty was only four point nine
million metric tons and represented a
small component of the overall vegetable
oil world now it dominates it it's the
leading oil and it actually passed soy
oil some somewhere in the early 90s in
terms of the most traded oil but now it
totally dominates the vegetable oil
sector then then followed by so I'm so I
just had this tremendous growth of this
growth really has been driven by a
number of factors primarily one you see
the increasing incomes and prosperity in
countries like India and in China and
the growth that changing diets in those
countries has really driven increased
consumption of palm oil and edible oils
in general when you take a look at where
this expansion has taken place you can
see in the left-hand chart just the
growth at 2.5 million metric tons per
year and still growing still growing
strong will get
to that a little bit later but the
growth is also is primarily centered in
Indonesia and Malaysia in terms of the
two kind of regional centers where palm
is produced when you look at it from a
global perspective you've got roughly
eighty eight percent of global palm oil
coming from two countries with Indonesia
having the lion's share and then
Thailand and Colombia following and you
are seeing the industry expanding in
Colombia and right now you you know in
terms of public announcements the next
wave of expansion or something like 2.5
million hectares of claims that
companies will be developing in in West
Africa West and Central Africa now when
you take a look at the consumption of
palm oil and where is being consumed
this is not about the US this is not
about Europe okay and that's one of the
big misperceptions many people have had
that it's our consumption has been
driving this is primarily India its
Indonesia China then then the you in
terms of representing the the primary
consumers of palm oil but then the rest
of it is consumed in a lot of the
developing world it is a widely used fry
while in the developing countries and so
this this is really critical when you
think about it in terms of how do you
transform the sector when and you want
to use market drivers ie your
multinationals if you will how do you
bring them to a to this problem to
actually have an impact on consumption
and unused in countries like China and
India and products that they are
producing its up the WWF we've gone
through all of this and have really had
to rethink our strategies I'd like to
say we kind of add a Western facing
strategy on an Eastern facing problem
and so things like RSPO are only part of
the solution because getting
certification into some of these
countries is going to be much much more
difficult in terms of driving driving
that pressure if you take a look at the
growth you can see
just where it is and where us
consumption is relative to the other
other top consuming countries the
Justice an interesting footnote you can
see the u.s. consumption is doubled
literally in a you know from 2004 to
2007 that was driven primarily because
of the trans fat issue companies moving
away from hydrogenated oils to to palm
oil and their various processed foods
but you can just see the growth in India
skyrocketing you can see it in China and
you can see it in the in India as well
it's really kind of really driving the
growth of consumption so what happened
the impacts this is just a graphic we
can do the same person watching just
kind of showing how the land cover the
forest cover has changed on Borneo and
you can see in this whole lowland area
right here in the lower part here that's
kind of the epicenter of where palm oil
is now being developed in Western and
Central Kalimantan and just flying over
that area about a year or so ago I mean
it's just literally now just all
blanketed with palm trees throughout No
so what have been the enabling
conditions what's what's done this first
of all it's highly profitable here's a
cropped where you were selling at one
point the price got up to one of twelve
hundred dollars a metric ton for
something that costs three hundred fifty
dollars to produce so highly profitable
for for the producers relative to other
oils it's highly productive and a much
lower price you have weak governance
systems and weak enforcement you have
strong support by both local and
national governments that have really
been pushing the growth of palm you have
consumption growth primarily in China
ngn Indonesia you have a wide range of
unbranded products again the vegetable
oils that are sold in Southeast Asia are
mainly unbranded and it's a highly
versatile oil with a wide range of
application so that it's being used in
many different sectors when you take a
look at the the yield issue it's
literally 10 times the yield of soy oil
on a per hectare basis now you're seeing
a movement right now in Europe in terms
of well let's get out of palm oil
entirely let's switch over to soy or to
sunflower or other oils the thing is is
that you know for every hectare a palm
oil that you take out for every ton of
palm oil that you take out of a company
supply chain you're potentially adding
two and a half Hector's persuade to
cover that and so you really have some
tough trade-offs here so the the main
focus really should be getting palm oil
right and and rather than trying to
substitute because from a land use
perspective you will run into problems
you can see here the growth in Indonesia
now the yellow bars that you see that
we're going to talk about that later on
but you just have a just this rapid
rapid growth and a very young tree age
distribution and that's important
because the younger tree age will raise
the productivity and you've got all of
these areas coming into production with
very very high productivity and that's
going to cause an interesting situation
in the markets going forward and I'll
talk about that later on you have yield
and degraded lands presents a huge
opportunity but huge policy obstacles
this is a photo of an area that was
burned out in the forest fires in 1998
in West Kalimantan it's completely
covered in the llangollen grasslands you
can go for 50 miles in any direction
from here and see the same kind of
landscape this land cannot be planted
and palm oil the government won't let
you okay it's part of the forest estate
with in Indonesia and it's being part of
the forest estate it is prohibited to
plant palm oil there so you have a lot
of areas that have been damaged but
there are policies and legal impediments
to actually using these lands for
expansion rather than forested areas so
it's a huge opportunity but requires a
change in policy
then you've got the issue of enforcement
this is just coming from you know the
jakarta post were in central kalimantan
where the anti judicial mafia as they
call it did a complete investigation of
all of the concessions that were granted
or or not concessions granted but the
plantation and mining firms 967
companies where they found only 76 had
deforested legally so you've got about
ninety two percent that were where the
deforestation was illegal in the case of
the plantations that came out to
seventy-nine percent so you just have
kind of a systemic failure around the
enforcement issues that just enables
people to to pretty much do what they
want without any kind of replications of
fear of accountability this is another
another situation this is the purple
spots in this map here are what they
call the ISM lokasi and these and put in
CPS and these are startup permits that
the local governments issue to companies
that want to plant palm oil they're all
outside of the forest estate and they're
all controlled by the local districts
and the provincial governments 5.3
million hectares of these permits were
issued of which only nine 5.3 million
Hector's were issued of which only nine
hundred thousand hectares were actually
planted in palm oil and so what this
ended up being was really just to work
around to go out and log and it's
illegal to log in these areas but as a
workaround I'm going to take up the
forest to plant palm oil but their
intentions were basically to take off
the timber and and to sell it off and
never to plant the palm oil so you have
a whole nother set of problems there
we're currently doing a study in the Rio
province right now we're taking a look
at just where the palm is being planted
and overlaying that with reserves and
parks and everything else and found that
twenty-five percent of the palm area
just in the province of Rio is illegal
as illegally planted 27 is legal and
forty-eight percent is unclear that
needs further investigation but twenty
twenty-five percent planted in areas
where it is illegal to produce and so
again it's an issue of accountability
then here we have the case of Tesso Nilo
National Park this is a park in in the
Rio province forty-three percent of this
park has been completely overrun by palm
oil on that smallholders a average
holding sizes 50 hectares and most of it
is recent and so you just see this
concern where even even national parks
aren't safe so you really have this
accountability that's governance and
this enforcement issue that is one of
the prime and abling factors that that
is happening if we take a look now at
the sector's in terms of the production
countries it's just a quick overview and
Malaysia of twenty-nine percent of
Malaysian production is smallholder base
nine percent in government hands 62 in
the private sector and in Malaysia which
you see in the private sector piece it
really isn't that concentrated five
companies control fifteen percent of the
production so it's really not a very
concentrated sector with it so it's got
many many players when you go to
Indonesia the profile is fairly similar
it's got a bit more smallholders a bit
more government but when you get to the
private sector it's very concentrated
six producers make up sixty percent lets
you know golden agri willmar and Astra
the top three producers in Indonesia
very very large companies with you
hundreds of thousands of Hector's and
production each of them in terms of
producing so you've got two different
two different aspects want a very
concentrated a very powerful players and
in Malaysia a much more diffuse and less
concentrated industry when you take a
look at
palm oil is being used globally a lot of
people you know thinkin's bio fuels
biofuels has not played a big big role
in problem it's about four percent of
total palm oil consumption the main
driver has been driven by cooking oil
and food industry years you're starting
to see a lot in the oleochemical center
primarily driven more by palm kernel oil
but the primary use has always been
really around food and biofuels
increasing but has not played a
significant role so far in the sector if
you take a look at the structure of the
traders and the market summary you've
got in India your traders are mu CMOS in
willmar walmart has thirty five percent
of the those two companies make up
thirty five percent of the trader
markets very low concentration terms of
the main use of seventy-two percent is
used as a cooking oil eighty percent of
that cooking oil is unbranded and its
retail structure very very fragmented
when you go to China you've got willmar
is seventy percent of the Chinese market
so dominant company one company very
very dominant and very concentrated in
terms of its used forty-six percent in
cooking oil sixteen percent in instant
noodles no this is surprising thing
instant noodles actually as a sa product
across the board make up about five
percent of global consumption of Hamas I
just don't want product you've got a
fairly concentrated years in terms of
the Chinese market in terms of the
cooking oil again it's 64% unbranded and
one company dominates with over fifty
percent of the Chinese market its master
con uses over a million tons of palm oil
a year and its retail structure again
highly fragmented a lot of Mama pop but
but but it's changing when you go to
Indonesia I you've got willmar golden
agri mu CMOS as the top traders of the
oil again Glomar showing up eighty
percent of the consumption is it's
cooking oil seventy-five percent of that
cook
oil is unbranded and again your retail
is highly fragmented and the EU cargo
will mar musa mas about 75% of the
European market but cargo and cargo
being the dominant player and the EU
market the main uses fifty-four percent
as Fugees and and the oleochemical is as
foo Jesus ingredients and the
oleochemical industrial products is
growing within the EU so the main
takeaway here is that you're dealing
first of all on the trailer space some
very very concentrated players with
willmar being a dominant theme
throughout this right willmar as a
company has about forty-five percent of
global palm oil okay so there are very
very dominant dominant player and in the
supply chain but you don't see much
concentration on the retail or on the
manufacturing end so the main place in
terms of the overall supply chain really
is isn't processing and trading and will
more is the dominant player here that is
a critical component so what's important
about this analysis is really is helping
us to figure out who do we focus on and
who do we have to talk to and who do we
have to change in terms of making
progress in the overall debate if you
take a look at quick breakdown of the
the traders again forty five percent on
global but it plays a dominant role in
China play some role in India and some
role in Europe but the others Cargill is
only big in in Europe and mu CMOS is the
leader in blue CMOS and whoops and will
Mar the two key players in India now
what's going on is stalking before in
terms of global pricing you've seen a
significant shift or change in the
marketplace right now and it's actually
an opportunity
oil has been in short supply literally
for the last eight years or so it's been
very very tight and since I've joined
WWF this is the first time or I actually
see that we do have an opportunity to
influence now because price is coming
way way down and so now it's going to be
about market access it is no longer a
seller's market it's going to be a
buyers market because you've got all of
this production coming online you can
just see the historical pricing trends
palm oil against soy and the canola oil
you can just see the big separation
happening right now on palm oil the
price is continuing to go down and
what's happening is is that there's just
been a massive buildup in inventory in
production they have too much in
production of the problem with the tree
crop as you can't turn them off okay so
they're always going to be producing
that oil is always going to be there and
so we're for saying that we will have a
soft market going forward and that also
we hope will slow down the expansion so
now to talk a little bit about the RSPO
since talking about sort of the efforts
on certification and kind of what's
going on there first of all right now
you know the RSPO is probably the
leading voice or format where producers
NGOs retailers growers all get together
and are able to talk about how to move
the industry in the appropriate sector
it really hasn't you know it hasn't I
would say from our perspective it hasn't
satisfied all of our requirements in
terms of what WWF is looking for but it
is actually the only format forum where
you've got where you can have the
discussions with the producers and move
them to higher ground as a certification
it's done fairly well its uptake has
been about twelve thirteen percent of
global production which isn't a bad
place in the short time that it's been
around but the problem and the concern
that I've got is that I think we've got
sort of our limitations in that RSPO
when you take
look at the market EU and us being about
twelve percent of global palm oil RSPO
is around twelve thirteen percent we've
really kind of saturated our natural
market if you will and then if we're
really going to be successful it's all
about China it's all about India and
it's all about Indonesia in terms of
driving progress the rspo was set up to
bring everyone together to discuss and
to come together with principles and
criterias around palm oil production the
standard went live in november two
thousand eight and it's been growing
ever since you take a look at the makeup
and how it's changed I know some of you
have had questions about that the RSPO
started off literally with some of the
more progressive producers or those
willing to engage that were will say at
some kind of brand exposure companies
like Sime Darby United plantations which
is a Danish company as well as a few
others WWF Unilever as a consuming
company and at that time when the RSPO
started the growers actually made up the
major major percentage what you're
seeing is a huge huge shift though in
the last few years as you're starting to
see a lot more of the consumer goods
companies coming into the debate and
becoming members of the RSPO and so
that's that's brought a lot more
pressure but it's also to some degree
we're seeing a lot more polarization
within the RSPO now in terms of how to
move things forward membership right now
is primarily Malaysia and Indonesia and
then every other company is pretty much
Western we do not we're just starting to
get indian companies and chinese
companies to join but getting those
companies into the rspo to become part
of the debate is going to be very
important right now it is still very
Western dominated terms of where the
RSPO is right now it's got a total of
1.5 million or 6.7 million pound
of palm certified of which they so
slightly more than half and so we're
having a real uptake issue the growers
are all saying as we want to increase
the stringency of the standard this
thing why we're going to increase the
berries increase the standard one at the
same time that they aren't seeing any
benefit or the the buyers of the brands
are not stepping up to the plate and
buying their oil we also have added
layers of complexity to this issue in
terms of the supply chain management
which I think have also been barriers in
terms of segregated and mass balance
versus book and claim you're seeing a
growth in your book and claim area
rather in your in your segregated in
your mass balance area that is as a lot
of costs that also poses a barrier for
the consumer goods companies in terms of
buying buying the physical oil rather
than going through a book and claim
system we'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute the problem that
we've got on the supply chain issue that
makes it incredibly complex is that when
you take palm oil and you fraction ate
it you can fraction ate it too many
different components in many different
products and the problem is how do you
track all of that through a supply chain
and keep it separate that adds enormous
cost to the supply chain a lot of
inefficiencies and so that makes it very
very difficult and very very costly to
get a specific fraction that is isolated
that has come from a certified
plantation now the booking claims system
was set up to take a lot of that
complexity out at least during the
initial stages but the consumer goods
companies have a lot of concerns about
whether or not the consumers would
accept a book and claim system in the
short term and their feeling is is that
they have to have segregated oil rather
than
a book and claim system and so we've got
this kind of a standoff with companies
not willing to pay the huge
inefficiencies at close to segregate the
palm oil and an unwillingness to to put
a process in place that would get us
there so when you take a look at kind of
the implications of that which he sees
you've got 6.7 million metric tons
produced of which 3.5 roughly were sold
of that 3.5 984 just under a million was
segregated and booking claimed all of
that cut sold all of the other producers
that had the certificates from the book
and claim system you know you ended up
with essentially a minority or
fifty-seven percent of the producers
receiving absolutely no kind of premium
or update for their oil because they
were part of a book and claim system and
so it's just become enormously complex
but the problem is is that the benefits
aren't getting to the producers now the
companies that can do the book and claim
are the big vertically yep booking
claims system is a you get certified and
so you have plantation say for 10,000
tons so us a producer get a certificate
for 10,000 tons and there's a market
called green palm where you can sell
that it's a secondary market so he is a
producer puts that certificate into that
market not a company like Unilever can
go and say I'll buy your certificate and
buy it the money goes right back to the
grower the segregated system is you've
got to keep the oil segregated and
separate all the way through that supply
chain so from extraction shipping and
refining and further fractionation
whatever you have to keep it separate
all the way through right that adds huge
inefficiencies to the system and huge
costs but it's the only way that a brand
can say well the palm oil that I've got
in my product is actually certified
right book and claimed facilitates that
in terms of makes it easier at least to
get bent
it's to a producer at least at the very
beginning stages if you get to say up to
fifty percent it's going to be a lot
more cost effective to segregate because
you're going to have that critical mass
but now you don't and so it's just very
very expensive so you have this problem
with the update the other problem is is
that those that produce the segregated
are the sime darby's the iOS these big
vertically integrated companies that are
all the way through the supply chain big
plantation base big refining base big
shipping base the whole thing sells for
them they can do it fairly easily so
when companies go out tho buy all their
segregated so they're getting that
benefit but on top of it you know this
is where I think the consumer goods
companies are making a big mistake if
they want to do they want to completely
fill their requirements to be a hundred
percent certified they'll buy
certificates to make up the difference
of what they need from the same people
so you aren't getting a good
distribution of benefits so you have the
grower saying why do we have to certify
or why do we even have to increase the
hurdle rate because we aren't getting
any benefit so you've got this big
problem right now that they aren't
seeing the benefits and we've got these
companies very concerned about moving
towards a book and claim system to help
move move the agenda forward right so
it's a bit of a problem so I mean this
is what this chart here is we're at
twelve percent now and so I mean what
we're suggesting is is that everyone
should be going with booking claim right
now there is no reason that company
can't be a hundred percent right now
through book and claim the certificates
are there move migrate to a mass balance
system in that the segregated system as
you increase your certification base
from a production standpoint that way
you avoid the economies of scale issue
you're taking a sort of a long term
sequence process approach to this but
unfortunately right now the consumer
goods companies are just very concerned
about how their consumers would perceive
this in their product and so that's kind
of big been a big standoff
okay so what's WWF doing and all of this
first of all we've been working with a
lot of the consumer goods companies
getting them to make commitments on a
hundred percent certified sustainable
palm oil working with the consumer goods
form and their declaration to eliminate
deforestation from their supply chains
and actively participating in the RSPO
and in various working groups within the
RSPO we've also completely revised our
strategy to really bring China India and
Indonesia into the fold and to build out
our capacity but also to engage the
private sector and the government's in
those countries to to begin the
discussions and and to move move the
issue forward in those markets and then
on policy looking at degraded lands
looking at the legality issues and we'll
be doing a few papers on legality as
well as looking at possible tariff
tariff benefits or tariff tariff
incentives that may may help move this
along principally in India where there
seems to be interest in the government
to do so so we're building out technical
capacity in our key markets as I said
and building out the local capacity to
engage the industry expanding our eyes
on the forest program this is a program
that we have in Sumatra looking at the
pulp and paper sector that's doing a lot
of monitoring and GIS work on
concessions and having them move into
the palm oil sector to start working on
that and also developing and much more
global to local communication strategy
so current activities in China is
working with the CFA it's a government
trade agency trade association very
critical have taken them down to
Indonesia and to Malaysia to see the
problems in the field have built out a
retailer working group have gotten
state-owned enterprises like Kafka which
is the biggest importer in China to
actually join the RSPO on Kafka was
actually just in December brought in the
first shipment of certified oil
have actually built out a noodle round
table because in China it's a huge huge
impact I mean master Kong is huge and
then working with the cgf companies in
India again working with the retailer's
forming a retailer working group working
with the refiners the government and the
cgf companies and Indonesia legality
smallholders certification and working
with the cgf companies there in terms of
moving the agenda forward pretty much in
terms of an overview yep questions QA
sure looks the same physically the oil
you can't tell one from another put on
the plantations itself where it's
developed it's got your buffer zones
stop planted on and then I'm deep Pete
it's not planted on steep hills all your
riparian areas are hcv areas and me
forested or forested and you've got your
worker rights issues your housing
medical care and all of those issues as
part of the whole package yeah
right and the problem that you're
absolutely right and the problems in
Indonesia are just incredibly
complicated I mean one of your biggest
drivers is also just the corruption that
you have the photo of the national park
that you saw there you have a member of
the Indonesian legislature is one of the
big investors in there okay you've got
major players in the palm sector that
had been buying up all of that
production you've got the intelligence
services of Indonesia involved as
brokering the fruit coming out of that
national park so you've got some
systemic issues that really have to be
dealt with in a much broader same
changing the changing the policies but
not working on the the enforcement and
the legality issues are going to be
really big I mean this is really one of
the biggest problems that we face really
is going to be this corruption issue
right we're providing a lot of
information to all of the corruption
forces that are there in terms of
mapping out the concessions identifying
the legality issues and all of that and
hopefully in the next couple of weeks or
so you'll be seeing something coming out
specifically on this whole investigation
on the National Park in terms of what
was behind it who was behind it one of
the sort of temple magazine which is
very similar to sort of the Indonesian
very much a
name and shame type of magazine or 60
minutes news magazine in Indonesia that
both in bahasa and in English has a
whole investigative team going through
this whole thing so we want to expose it
bring it bring it out because it's got
to become part of the debate right but
it's a huge issue in Indonesia and it's
not just Palmer closed to fishing
because it goes to pulp and paper ever
every sector there i mean it's it's a
you know systemic issue yes it's
terrible it's terrible the the peat
lands you mean yeah that has to be one
of the dumbest things I've ever seen it
people planting on Pete if you go to a
plantation that's planted on Pete and
it's fairly old what you see is the the
trees laying on their size falling down
very very difficult to fertilize very
very weak root systems and this terrible
terrible productivity when Greenpeace
went after golden agri one of the
declarations that Greenpeace had golden
I agree sign was no more Pete you know
it said that you know Frankie would Jaya
selects that's a good thing we shouldn't
be planning our Pete it was dumb to
begin with right what makes Pete
attractive is its availability okay and
that's that's the issue it's about land
and its availability and so if you've
got nothing or Pete people are choosing
pieten you're seeing a lot of Pete in in
the smallholder context in terms of
people smallholders holding our planning
about a couple of Hector's on Pete land
because it's available but it's from a
production standpoint it's not good at
all
sure you can plant pastures very easily
and the little pretties fine I mean
that's that whole degraded lands issue
in terms of in the Indonesian context
it's really about the alangalang
grasslands and these these are just
extensive grasslands that take over
after the fires have come in many people
thought that you couldn't plant palm and
in those areas because the grass is just
too aggressive where the fire risk was
too high but you can't eradicate the the
alangalang fairly easily and fairly
quickly in fact it's more cost effective
to do that than it is to clear a
secondary force to plant palm yes on to
some degree i would say really good i
mean i got to go see the hen doli
plantation that has big smallholder
independent grower community that you
know the plantation team there was
working very very closely with the
smallholders driving you know helping
provide input technical assistance all
of that kind of support they're
certified to RSPO highly highly
productive i mean they were getting very
very good yields and then you go into
the towns and what you're seeing is sort
of the you know the the indonesian
McMansions popping up you're seeing
banks and you're saying commerce
spreading and she really could see an
increase in livelihoods and some of the
more remote areas you know in terms of
providing community services electricity
water most of the plantation companies
do that educational facilities medical
facilities they all those are all part
of sort of that plantation package if
you will and for the most part of are
available to the locals but you know
that's only I'm from what I've seen I
haven't seen the horror stories right
those are very hard to get into yes yeah
the smallholder certification is a
difficult issue i think someone had
asked the questions about the thailand
experience and how you know how that
worked out with the smallholders that
cost the ifsc something like 2 million
dollars right to get that smallholder
group certified we're working with one
group the first thing that you really
have to do is aggregate some kind of
co-op a lot of training a lot of
Education in terms of bringing them
online that I think their biggest
problem that they've got long term with
the smallholders though really has more
to do with one very very poor yields
most of them because are very
extensively cultivated and so they're
viewed more as an opportunistic crap
rather than a managed scrub but then on
top of that you have the issues of poor
germplasm they're planting roadside ffb
which basically backcrosses to the
parent material and a much much lower
yield as well and so but the getup
certified it requires infrastructure I
mean we're building some of that out
groups like solar daddy dad are building
that out
I DHS building that out but it is it is
a massive task the plantation companies
for the most part aren't stepping up to
that in terms of working with the
independent smallholders as kind of one
of the strangest things I've seen
because when I was in the plantation
business we always would want to work
with our small holders and get them the
best technology make sure they have the
the fertilizers and everything else make
sure that they were trained because as
they benefited we would benefit as well
but over there they just don't see it
that way and so there's very much very
much a separation I'm quite a bit
especially with the independent small
holders that aren't affiliated with any
kind of plantation company yes give me
an example
some people have raised cattle
underneath but more on the and the older
and the older cultivations but years ago
we tried to grow papaya didn't work out
too well haven't seen haven't seen
really much on that were where we're
seeing that really emerging is more in
the coconut coconut and cacao in our
planning okay and hopefully we'll be
getting a project up and running down
that in the Philippines but again small
holder and more likelihood striven but
no it's really not it's not front and
center within the industry it's still
pretty much a mono crop but but within
that you know one of the big paradigms
within sort of the palm plantation and
you're starting to see some of that in
terms of letting the understory grow
right and letting that build up and I've
seen a few plantations doing that more
on an experimental basis and monitoring
for changes in biodiversity and that
kind of thing but nothing on a large
scale right sure curly
wish I could answer that the thing the
way I would look at it is that you know
if we aren't a hundred percent
successful we failed okay if you get
eighty percent you still got twenty
percent doing the damage and they can do
considerable damage right but I think
we've got to you know some of the good
developments that are happening or at
least I perceive them as good we'll see
how they play out as the RSPO has been
gaining force or traction within the
sector you're seeing a concern response
by the government's both Indonesia and
Malaysia okay Indonesia is now has come
out with the ISPO Indonesian sustainable
palm oil which essentially is mandatory
that's mandatory compliance with some of
the laws of Indonesia so they got to
really make sure that some of the laws
are being followed and audit all the
plantations by 2015 all plantations have
to be certified in Indonesia with ispo
Malaysia is following up with something
similar now to some degree I mean you
know some say that that's a bad thing
that's going to create competition but I
think what it is really doing is just
showing up the bottom I mean at the end
of the day how we would spell success
right now is how do we stop the
deforestation right and so you know i
don't think the RSPO can do that and I
think we need many other different type
of interventions it's not just there is
no silver bullet on this you've got to
work on many many different angles right
right well globally but in China is
something like twelve percent of Chinese
palm well right right right well yeah
it's it's you know get getting the
noodle manufacturers and what we really
want to do is we want the phones ringing
from Beijing to Jakarta you know I need
sustainable palm well right and so we're
meeting with master Kong and other
noodle manufacturers on on the issue the
latest report that we've had is getting
master Kong to join RSPO and that's and
discussions right now to get them
involved to take them down this so that
they can see see the impacts and that's
one of the things that we have found
it's been very effective taking you know
these corporate executives to see what's
going on is very very effective because
they don't want to be a part of it when
they see it up front and close most are
angered okay on top of that we're
working with the cfa which helps
establish the policies for ministry of
commerce and all of that educating them
on rspo to get the chinese government
involved because the Chinese in China
anything you do you really have to have
the government behind you right so if
the government moves and that's why you
know having cofco coming in and I'll
bring in the first load of cspo is a
good thing because it's starting to lay
down a marker now the thing you know
from a political standpoint palm oil is
not a big issue in China right because
China's main source of oil is soy and so
you know we brought the palm oil issue
even to our own colleagues and WWF China
you know what are you talking about we
barely use this stuff but it's all
relative right it's big China's big the
palm oil but palm oil is not big to
China right and so it requires a lot of
education and so bringing the issue
you to them getting companies like cough
go getting the CF na involved and
getting master Kong and the noodles as
well as the retailer's had a number of
meetings with various retailers and
consumer goods firms trying to get them
to step up but the big surprise was you
know in about November I was having
lunch with willmar in China and we'll
Marsh people and China did not know
anything about Rs p.m. right and so it's
just how do you penetrate that down now
kinda it's just multiple multiple
activities and a lot of Education yeah
yeah I do yeah I do 4422 two reasons
first of all is just taking a look at
the lands that are available you've got
to deal with those policy issues you
know those low carbon lance and they're
there right there's actually a map of
that low carbon lands will be published
very very soon globally in terms of the
the tropical areas where are these areas
that are you know 30 tons of carbon or
less so you can do that second of all
the sheet she G upside and yield I mean
if you take a look at you know that your
best companies are getting 7 7.5 tons of
oil per hectare ok indonesia's average
is 3.9 so there's a big upside on that
as well then there's also new varieties
and new I mean sime darby has it as a
clone out right now that is reportedly
getting something like 11 tons of oil
per hectare and so there's still palms
are relatively new cultivation and
they're just starting to bring a lot of
the technology and breathing to it it
takes now just to get a palm oil variety
clone tested and everything else it
takes about 20-25 years and so there you
know you're starting to see some of that
pain off but I do think it's possible
it's just a question of you know
building out and getting with the
policies right and moving the industry
in the right direction right yes
and which one the one that I talked
about in Sumatra and so it's acted upon
constantly on the pulp and paper of the
pulp and paper sector it's a it's a
ongoing effort there the the numbers
that I gave you on a real right now that
is going to be in a report coming out
hopefully in the next month or so okay
in terms of publishing the preliminary
analysis of what they found in Riau in
terms of the legality our pivot for
Indonesia right now is really going to
be to start talking about legality in a
much more public fashion right to get
that issue out because it's if you bring
the legality issue out I mean if you
look at it this way Indonesia's about
fifty to fifty three percent of global
palm oil a company like Unilever is not
going to want to buy palm oil that may
be tainted with national park okay and
so if you're able to tie those supply
chains with legality you're going to end
up forcing the companies and the traders
to start doing that due diligence and
and enforcing that because it's sick
yeah they're going to need market access
and access is going to be a big issue as
you see their inventories building up
and and prices going down right and so
really pushing that part of the this
thing will help those companies respond
we've talked with Walmart well Mars
policy has been we will not be policemen
for the industry right but the biggest
problem that they have as a company and
they openly admit it we don't even know
where our oil comes from okay now here's
a company that trades forty-five percent
of global palm well and has absolutely
no traceability right that's not a good
place to be
they're going to have to they're going
to have to they're going to have to
because it becomes a very much a
reputational issue for Indonesia right
palm oil is important Indonesia huge
revenues from the Indonesian government
market access is huge right now I mean
the Indonesian government is lobbying
very very hard the US EPA to get palm
oil approved as a biofuel for free for
the US because what they've got to do
they've got this huge inventory that's
building on this wall of oil is going to
be coming online they kind of expand the
uses or it's just going to fill up all
the tanks over there right so they've
got to find additional uses for palm oil
so they're really lobbying very very
hard you know the art context and EPA
and department of state are telling us
it's an incredibly sensitive issue with
the US government right now so bringing
the legality issue out is very very
important for us to do right yes right
now we don't recommend it as a biofuel
absolutely not I mean the last thing and
we tell this very very clearly I mean
told it directly to the minister of
forestry is it why would we want to
encourage us consumers to help destroy
national parks until you can show me
that you can protect your parks we
aren't going to encourage the
consumption yes
could you speak up a little bit right
not not really it's the problem is I'm
in the u.s. is only two percent I mean
I'd rather spend my time I hate to say
it on noodles I mean there's just bigger
bang for buck right in terms of the u.s.
is only two percent of the market yes
it's very important it's very important
and for the most part most of the brands
have been very very active I mean you
know I'm surprised that a lot of the lot
of the companies have been doing in
terms of really driving driving the
conversation I mean there's a whole
group that is you know quietly talking
to the Indonesian government fix this we
want to do business with you but we
can't you know we can't constantly have
these type of problems whether it's palm
oil or whether it's pulp and paper you
guys have to get this under control
right so we're trying to bring the
commercial arguments to the government
so that they understand that that
there's also is about money and it's
also about they're essentially license
to operate to plan on a global stage now
yes yeah great question I'm a fan of
really just laying out let's do that
land use planning exercise let's lay out
where you can or cannot plan that's
essentially what the sway moratorium did
absolutely no expansion in the Amazon
right but let's define those areas right
I think that that's something that
really has to happen and really take a
look at a lot of those policy
interventions whether it's the forest
estate or outside of the forest estate
to see where are the most suitable
places that do the least damage right in
terms of a moratorium SOI SOI in Brazil
was easy because you know so dependent
on Europe okay and so it's really you
had a lot of market pressures there you
don't have that with palm oil so to to
get everyone to agree to any kind of
stopping the moratorium unless the
Chinese the Indians and the Indonesians
say no it's not going to happen yes
you know in China you see a lot of
concern around the environmental issues
growing but it's really about what's
front and center to them in terms of
whether it's the water of the pollution
in Beijing or what have you something
that is very very close to them they
have very very little knowledge about
the palm oil issue in general and the
consumption pattern of this I mean it's
an unbranded product that's going
through such you know wide-ranging
distribution networks and things like
that I think it would be very very hard
to really get consumers up and running
we want to focus our time and energy
more on government and you know those
key state-owned enterprises as well as
the cgf firms and the noodle guys